My name is Angela and I am a freelance consultant specializing in digital analytics.
Data can't talk to you, right?
It's not a person you can go like, "How are you feeling today?" ...
...and says, "I feel like I'm under the weather and I kinda have a cough."
I make things easier to find.
I make information accessible.
I help companies serve their customers better.
I know this sounds ridiculous, but I wake up in the morning thinking about math all the time.
I'm thinking of this sphere of data that you can turn around in your mind...
...and get all these different perspectives on it.
People would ask me what I did for a living...
...and somewhere it just dawned on me like, I'm kinda like a math detective,...
...like I'm solving mysteries but with math.
My job is just completely in sync with how I see the world.
I just love it.
I love every second of it.